é dado a todos é vou falar se a
fotografia nesta visita de construção
mas antes mais acho que é importante
desconstruir mim mesmo e responder à
pergunta quem é que sou eu
basicamente o meu nome é daniel fonseca
vem no meu site tinyurl.com goiás pensar
porque como em casa trazendo chama
felipe ninguém me chama daniel só 26
daniel f fonseca e assim no momento que
eu apresentei e podem ter aquela
fotografia que ela não foi tirada com o
iphone mas foi provavelmente é a
primeira fotografia que realmente me
entusiasmou para levar mais a sério é o
mundo da fotografia e isto porque apesar
de aparecerem duas vezes não há nenhum
truque photoshop apenas simplesmente
reduzir a velocidade com que a
fotografia tirada e como apenas a única
fonte de iluminação que existam em uma
vela e consegui estar num não se depois
avance para o outro e só quando está
muito parado em que a quem é que fica
registado até que as fotografias muito
antigas que aparecem as primeiras
aparecem com os filiados todas vazias
é só porque a câmera demorava tanto
tempo a fotografar nenhuma pessoa ficava
assustado e isso te chama pensará e essa
é curioso isso comecei então álvaro que
mais a sério fotografia
além disso eu sou casado tem dois filhos
vamos ao rio de onde aliás sou do porto
originalmente yamu sou diretor martin da
profissão que tem dinheiro
o backstage de um não se estava a gravar
um capital para escutar só serve para 5
por cento das pessoas que ligam as
marcas e aí o fato de trabalhar 0,5 por
cento das flores coisa coisa está mal é
mas depois que você pensa em nada a
forma com uma máquina aborda é a
realidade disse não para a outra forma
de olhar para isto é mais fácil fazer
melhor do que o pior não é que começamos
com 0,5 e pra baixo é mais difícil
atualmente estou trabalhará em
inglaterra não foi forçado a emigrar
felizmente mas surgiu uma oportunidade e
portanto aí que eu que estou totalmente
a trabalhar
sou apaixonado da fotografia não sou nem
pouco mais ou menos profissional da
fotografia mas sou apaixonada fotografia
essencialmente viagem foi assim curso há
12 anos atrás
só tive a felicidade de visitar mais de
50 países e terá muita estrutura física
em todos os outros mas mais recentemente
há cerca de três anos talvez comecei a
fotografar com o iphone que o início de
ano do graf ar num telemóvel nesta ordem
católica mas a pouco e pouco foi
conquistando e consegue olhar para as
coisas de uma outra maneira de começar a
achar interessante esta outra forma de
tortura e tal maneira que depois
organizar então uma uma exposição apenas
pensamos é em lisboa e no porto e
consegue falar um bocadinho de estréia
fonográfica como é dever não fui eu que
inventei este conceituado fotógrafo que
ele desista seguirem na internet
vou falar mais sobre isso é com corria
um concurso a nível global e fui um dos
gestores e portanto agora olhe pra que é
o tipo do jornal
presidente eu sou eu acho que tem algum
site para tirar fotografia é como o
iphone
quando me convidaram pra falar aqui na
natex eu já no ano passado tinha dito
claro que sim
não dá mesmo para dizer que não também
ir ao alasca é mas como eu mesmo sou
fiel seguidor das conferências tempo diz
que sim
depois de ser um tema eu comecei a
pensar o que é a desconstrução anos como
é que eu vou falar de desconstrução
então fui à internet
fui ver a definição do dicionário exato
o efeito desconstruir
fiquei um carro na mesma depois fiel
equipe e então dentre as várias palavras
latinha não sabe então a dizer não
significa destruição significa
desmontagem de composição dos aumentos e
serve para descobrir partes que estão em
cima das casas lá isso realmente tem
alguma coisa a ver com aquilo que eu
faço quando um fotógrafo que maneira com
óleo para o objeto da fotografia não é
apenas aquilo que o estado nós estamos
aqui neste momento eo que nós estamos a
ver é eles público - mas há um limite
como podem pensar que são os pormenores
desta cadeira é desconstruir tudo que
temos à nossa frente e encontrar algo
que a partida está decidido a não se via
exatamente daquela maneira
vou falar um caminho disse então no
contexto da fotografia com o santo cura
por utilizar essas não quer dizer que
ela é um génio ea simplicidade com que
eu responda a esta pergunta então mas
como é que eu faço uma escultura é fácil
tirar do bloco magno aquilo que não é
necessário que o que quer dizer
simplesmente se constrói tem uma pedra
gigante um box mar mutirão que não é
necessário ser é já está pré simples
não vou comparar de maneira nenhuma que
ela em uma só que realmente conseguia am
capturar muito bem esta lógica de
desconstrução na fotografia
se a tecnologia ajudará na fotografia
comecei a pensar um crime racionalizado
um cadinho eu chamo aqui tradicional
mais realista porque na minha fotografia
viagem eu tenho uma determinada
reportagem fotográfica
uma abordagem diferente tanto é que é
mais mais realista tem mais a ver com
essa desconstrução da realidade atual
passa com a composição escolha do banco
a inspira a perspectiva é questão da
abertura do diafragma velha máquina que
basicamente quer dizer que tá pra ficar
tudo ficava lá pra escolher uma parte
está focado já está desfocado vos tirada
que nos vamos mostrar nos vemos vai ser
mais claro a entender a seguir e ea cor
ou a sua ausência mas em geral têm mais
a ver com aquilo que é com a realidade e
podendo então alguns exemplos de
desconstruir aquilo que temos à nossa
frente
por exemplo esta fotografia tirada em
paris
sim quando nós chegamos a torre eifel
não é necessariamente esta visão que
temos razão terminado o ângulo em que se
nós nos colocarmos à exatamente esta a
imagem que temos e pra mim para ser uma
imagem especialmente interessante eu
acho que acaba por ter até uma mensagem
de contemplação da admiração com aquela
obra arquitetônica e portanto tem a ver
com este construída que nós vemos de uma
forma diferente para lidar com outra
realidade
esta outra é o exemplo tiravam a nu no
tibete
quando vemos o total a ea bandeira
chinesa por cima quem segue o mínimo da
política internacional sabe com a
supremacia chinesa sobre sobre o tibete
é pena olhar de outra maneira e
construir uma imagem que não está
necessariamente lá
à primeira vista ou isto é um centro
comercial no japão em que na verdade eu
não tô fotografar sede social acaba por
ser tudo abstrato são apenas linhas
aéreas geometria que eu achei
interessante e pela perspectiva neste
caso que está a tirar picados baixo para
cima então criei uma imagem que uma vez
mais a mim pareceu interessante estiver
a perspectiva contrária
tivemos um exemplo num mercado flutuante
bangcoc que uma vez mais também venham
conjunto círculos 15
nuno barco aqui deste lado que fazem são
formas uma vez mais são as formas que
torna instante as cores com a ausência
praticamente certa aqui o seu papel e do
lado já é uma visão também diferente
daquela mesma realidade e que torna
fotograficamente o objeto mais
interessante o próximo exemplo tem a ver
com a questão da abertura ou escolher o
foco por exemplo com com esta imagem mas
que não conseguimos perceber um pouco do
contexto ou seja aquela que o liga à fia
a nota top está estamos a observar algo
no país
a área é jordânia neste caso e o resto
desta com carinho a interpretação quase
consegue eu acho que torna mais curioso
sem se mostrar exatamente o que é que lá
está mas de alguma maneira por cento que
existam em uma balança com aquela roupa
que buscas atrás sou lá atrás a
contemplar mas o que é que este tipo
está aqui a fazer fotografada os seus os
meus produtos e uma vez mais é é tornar
interessante aquela que é o momento
porque porque foi escolhida uma opção de
fotografia desse porte neste caso ou
esta oeste inseto na namíbia que a
partir do momento em que o pacto tudo o
resto do ruído visual que existe
dou muito mais importância aquilo que é
objeto da linha fotografias conseguir
ver atrás reservas e e as pedras e etc
acaba por se perder tudo por ficar tudo
é completamente é misturada a velocidade
também continuar o movimento rápido
neste caso um avião que estava um
hidroavião que estava acabado de
levantar da bahia siga na equipe fica
com os lado ali no tempo ou exatamente o
contrário que é conseguir fazer o tal
arrastamento do movimento
no texto o malabarista né em casamento
na tailândia que está a fazer aquelas
suas brincadeiras com o fogo e que isso
não tem
photoshop com um aqui é apenas um
exemplo é a primeira fotografia que foi
mostrado em que consegue captar com o
star o movimento e criar então uma nova
realidade a cor tudo aquilo que me traz
aqui neste objeto era a cor mais nada é
esta no paulo em katmandu 11 figura
fantástica
esta fotografia ou ausência que não
tivesse um peregrino onde não é nada
mais do que a expressão do próprio é
sujeita a fotografia deste homem
distanciam que nem estava enfatizar
tanto não queria distração nenhuma não
queria sequer que acordou assumiu
momento aqui para nos ficarmos
exatamente naquilo que realmente
interessante foram é fotografia smas
tradicionais digamos assim
relativamente à obra feita e se muito
breve comentário à nova fase que a mente
é a arte de fotografar com o iphone não
acaba no momento em que fotografa porque
depois todo o processamento da
fotografia que faz a seguir e
normalmente a sua partilha é feita sem
qualquer recurso é um computador ao quer
que seja é tudo é feito com base na
emenda
então aí para mim a forma como eu
fotografo normalmente quando ficar com a
fama já é uma realidade há mais
adulterada propositadamente a demonstrar
como os filtros que utilizo pra a
posteriori perspectiva continuam a ser
importantes mas pois existe uma segunda
leva o uec composição por exemplo
utiliza muito o instagram por pensar
dentro do quadrado dentro porque senão
não funciona no honesta e os filtros
aqui o que é mas naquilo pode vir a ser
alguns exemplos é esta fotografia e vão
vir sempre ali no canto inferior direito
qual é que a fotografia original e
depois o resultado
depois de trabalhar um dia cinzento no
porto não acontece é e portanto é a
fotografia em si como estava não era uma
e as particularmente interessante mas
achei que havia ali qualquer coisa e
todos os clérigos bonita como é certeza
que havia de resultar num voltar bem e
por isso acontece é que tem muito mais
uma perspectiva de transformação da
alteração quase um quadro como resultado
final e não necessariamente mostrar a
realidade como ela é ou era uma vez mais
acho que foi no mesmo dia e que chove
muito as cores e trazer uma nova vida é
esta fotografia inicial e trazer também
esta componente quase em quase de
fantasia ao trabalhava tanto ao estoril
há tanto o qual reconstruiu a tantos
anos assim exemplo tamanho da terra e
está em lisboa a estação da gare do
oriente em que mais do que uma vez mais
tratar aquela realidade é um em três
estético de um metro da realidade
depois disto cível desconstruído aquilo
que realmente me interessa olhar pro
haiti mas pelo aqui qualquer coisa ao
sol ou estas formas a estas linhas e é
isto é isso que me interessa falar que
qualquer coisa há há há muitos milhares
de fotografias que eu também acho que
isso pesou em nada mas algumas que
escapam e que que realmente o resultado
é interessante esta do rio ave da alice
a fotografia original do canal um
corredor nem que na verdade o que me
interessava
o que o que eu realmente estava na areia
da praia 11 portanto vimos lembra de
tudo e acabei por cento apenas as formas
não diz nem toda a gente consegue
apanhar que não conhecendo o que é mas
para mim esta futura filha de imensa
apenas com 6 200 sombras que a classe se
tornar mais mágica foi o cristo rei até
amanhã em lisboa que uma fotografia acho
que tenho em tribunal
a tirada no carro é como se não façam
isso
mas aconteceu esta vez aconteceu e outra
que também vão gostar é macho que acaba
por depois de transformar pode ver não é
que eu tenha algum misticismo eu posso
encontrar algum vestígio e trabalhando
está desconstruindo aqui o que houve e
retrabalhando acaba por resultado
naquela imagem que vem além da fia é
curioso estava nu estava no algarve
junto à piscina eo meu primeiro a
primeira coisa que vi foi para a pista
está suja não limpar um banhista que não
tenham de alguma coisa e em 2000
sentados por e simplesmente porque no
iphone futura foi aquela que vem além de
trabalhar fiz várias experiências e que
os sintomas é uma das minhas fotografias
preferidas com o iphone tanto tem a ver
com isso com essa afinal o que é que
está lá o que é que não interessa desta
realidade ver um livro todo o resto e
centrar naquilo que eu quero transmitir
por isso vi então tal lançamento a
desconstrução e aquilo a forma como eu
faço quando estou aqui estou a
fotografar
não só isso conhecem é em matosinhos
esta venda dos pescadores nesta
instalação gigante é uma vez mais
cenário venha a ter mais cuidado com
isto também foi aguiar é e
mas não conseguiu resistir a tirar esta
esta fotografia e depois se transforma
em algo completamente abstrato
completamente abstratos nós não tivemos
aquela fluência é apenas é quase
matemática e olhe para este mês quase um
lugar ficou o matemático muito elaborado
mas gosto gosto muito de ver o resultado
final ou esta pois é mais uma tira a
consciência é pa
a minha mulher bem do estado não faça
chamadas ao tema nova quando trazia
consigo humanos mensagem fotografia mas
acontece quando o inverso foi tirada é
esta foi um esboço não tem erro né é um
ponto baixo é e também uma vez mais
região teria mais do que o hotel é
propriamente dito o resultado final
estou quase a acabar para dizer então
que na minha na minha visão a minha
perspectiva eu acho que o primeiro passo
para construir algo novo é desconstruir
ao que já existe
eu acho que tenha o espírito tem tudo a
ver com isso
como olhar para a realidade que nós
temos e desmontava e voltar a montar lá
como os líderes de israel voltar a
montar ou de uma maneira diferente mais
interessante e no retorno surpreendente
é para construir 11 jorge
muito obrigado